I have something for you today that I think
you're really going to enjoy.
Ivanka Trump, Donald Trump's daughter, who
is often
in positions of power in terms of being a
spokesperson or representative for the position
of the Trump administration, you might remember
is unelected.
She's not been elected to anything.
She's not confirmed by the Senate.
She would actually be precluded from holding
an official position because of anti-nepotism
laws.
She often sits in official government conversations.
She was recently interviewed by own spokeswoman,
a state department spokeswoman, a complete
and total farce meant to create the appearance
of accountability and of transparency and
of answering questions from the press.
Imagine if I was in some kind of scandal,
it could happen, right, and I said, I am going
to subject myself to questioning.
I will be transparent.
I am going to explain to you what I did and
why I did it and I will be held to account
and I will let the press talk to me and then
it's like my own PR staff that interviews
me, right?
You would say, well, what the hell are you
doing?
How is this transparency?
So Ivanka goes to the Doha forum in Doha,
Qatar or cutter as Tucker Carlson calls it,
big announcement that she would be speaking.
It's already sort of like, why is she going
to be speaking?
But okay, she's going to be speaking.
This immediately created an uproar of questions.
What is she doing in Qatar?
Is this some kind of signal to the Royal family
about something of some kind?
Is Jared Cushner going?
Of course, Jared Kushner's connections to
the region are problematic at best and downright
corrupt at worst, but then she shows up.
The room is filled with officials from all
over the world, actual officials being interviewed
by real journalists, asking actual questions
about policy and issues.
It's a forum actually known for tough interviews.
Lindsay Graham was there.
He got into a whole thing with a real journalist
about impeachment.
For example, the Rwandan president was asked
about term limits, which is an immediate and
very real issue in Rwanda.
Uh, the president there, um, uh, I believe
it's Paul Paul Kagami, uh, Kagawa Kagami I
believe.
So incomes, Ivanka Trump to be interviewed.
And the interviewer is Morgan Ortegas.
That's the same person I just quoted in the
last segment who told us why the Trump administration
is not going to be recognizing the Armenian
genocide as a genocide.
Morgan is the current state department spokesperson
and a former Fox news contributor and she
throws Ivanka utter softball questions.
For example, you were able to put women's
prosperity into the national security strategy.
That was so important to me that you did that
and I'd love for you to explain that.
Low transparency wow.
Ivanka is really going to have to account
for.
Oh, right.
It's bogus.
Speaking of travels, you've been in Morocco
recently, can you tell us more about the trip
and highlights?
Oh, well, we rode camels and I met some business
owners.
Another question.
You also returned on a swing through Latin
America with our deputy deputy secretary of
state, John Sullivan.
Can you tell us about some of your impressions?
Oh, it's so vibrant and what can everyone
hear that's representing the private sector
do?
Yeah.
That's a really hard hitting issue and with
all of the successes of the initial launch,
what are you doing to ensure that this lasts
much beyond your time in the white house?
A Russian journalist said at the event, even
Vladimir Putin doesn't get interviewed by
his own press secretary.
This is how what are effectively monarchs.
This is how monarchs are groomed, right?
In this case, Ivanka is sort of the equivalent
to the Queen's daughter or even the queen,
right?
I mean unelected, unconfirmed by a legislative
body in completely over her head.
This is how you groom monarchs controlled
audiences, controlled questions, calculated
FFO, transparency, biased press conferences
with softball.
Questions would never have a role in government,
were it not for her dad.
Not to mention, remember that the Trump kids
said they were going to try to stay out of
politics at the start of Trump's presidency.
That ship has obviously long sailed.
She's basically asking herself questions.
This is a crafted fake interview with the
spokeswoman that she traveled there with.
Now here's my question.
Is this an attempt to look important?
Like is this an ego thing for Ivanka Trump?
Is this because she simply couldn't handle
a real serious interview?
Is this because the people at the state department
realized that she shouldn't be there at all
and this is how they protect their own image
by making sure that she doesn't embarrass
the state department by virtue of being asked
real questions by actual journalists?
My question is, who do you think decides that
this is what they are going to do and what
is going to be done and at what point is it
decided and for what purpose?
Let me know by replying.
If you're watching on YouTube, leave a comment
or send me a tweet at Dee Pacman.